so we already discussed that Donald
Trump is clearly signaling to Paul man
afford that he's going to pardon him on
yesterday's program we talked about that
we don't know exactly who Trump will
pardon but we've now learned that
Republican leaders are panicking that
Trump is going to start dishing out
pardons like Halloween candy and that
it's going to be really really bad
there's a new report from MSNBC I'm
sorry from NBC News which says that a
senior Republican party source is hoping
Trump won't quote dig the hole any
deeper by handing out pardons to
Manafort Cohen and possibly others and
these same Republicans are worried that
if Trump does just start quickly and
haphazardly pardoning people including
Manafort and Cohen that it could make
the calls for impeachment grow even
further there's also a New York Times
report which confirms that Trump
discussed the repercussions of pardoning
Manafort with his lawyer Rudy Giuliani
and of course Rudy Giuliani seems to be
giving great legal advice to Donald
Trump
Giuliani told the New York Times that
pardoning manna Ford who of course on
Tuesday was found guilty on eight of 18
counts was not something that the
president was considering but who
believes that when Trump was asked
during that Fox News interview yesterday
or the day before
are you considering pardoning manna Ford
he didn't even answer the question
instead saying he has great respect for
a man afford which is yet another signal
that he probably is thinking of
pardoning the guy and not surprisingly
Trump's aides are also worried that
Trump might have a complete and total
meltdown over the convictions at any
time
apparently Trump's been staying sort of
calm for the last day or so since the
guilty verdicts and counts against Cohen
and mana Ford but the staff surrounding
Donald Trump is acutely aware that at
any point he might implode and that's
that's where we are like how wild is
that that the president is managed like
a little kid staffers are worried that
he'll have a meltdown the equivalent of
like a little kids tantrum and he has to
be placated with the propaganda file
twice a day where it's like screenshots
and printouts of positive tweets and
pictures of Trump looking powerful that
media have used he is managed
like a little child and he could launch
nuclear weapons at any time and there's
actually a fourth source quoted by NBC
News which use the term emotional
meltdown that there could be an
emotional meltdown at any time as a
result of these verdicts if trump isn't
having a meltdown at this point it's
because he doesn't understand how
serious the situation is I would
anticipate him losing his mind when he
actually finds out how serious this is
earlier in the in the week we did the
story from the New York Times about how
White House canceled counseled Don
McGann seemed to have full permission
from Trump to go and meet with Muller
and part of the reason why Trump didn't
seem to have a problem with the meetings
is Trump thought that White House
Council was there defending Trump even
though it's increasingly clear that
McGann was actually there as a
cooperating witness I think that's the
theme when Trump doesn't have a meltdown
over something that should anger him or
at least should concern him it's
probably because he doesn't get how
serious it is and I fully anticipate the
guy he's gonna completely lose his mind
when he actually figures out what's
going on he's mostly watching Fox News
right which has been covering when the
eight Cohen counts were breaking and the
eight guilty verdicts against Paul
Manafort were breaking they were
covering the Molly Tibbets case a
serious case but of course not something
that supersedes everything that's going
on with the President of the United
States he may not even understand how
serious this stuff is I think we've
started a new chapter with all of this
stuff for a new season if you will I
yeah the house of cards is going to
start falling down because you know I
mean maybe a few months ago there would
be an indictment here and then it would
be a few months before the next one or
something would break in the Russia
scandal but then there would be some
time before the next thing happened yeah
now it's every day something new and is
sustainable I think that based on so
yesterday we showed you the results of a
YouTube community poll that we did
13,000 sample size from people who watch
our show on YouTube and 42 percent
believe that Don jr. is going to be the
next Trump insider to get indicted if he
gets indicted
I can't imagine Trump's going to remain
calm that's going to set him off for
sure right yeah I mean Don jr. is one of
trumps three favorite sons yeah
think you would stick by sign there he's
definitely at least up there in some of
the some of his favorite people
even though wasn't he didn't we learn he
was recently calling him like boneheaded
or something for his involvement like
all of a sudden now he thinks Don junior
didn't handle the Trump Tower meeting
well or something like that like listen
it was insane to do it to begin with the
FBI should have been called how
understated is it to say I don't like
how Don jr. handled the Trump Tower
meeting they're gonna disavow his own
son in all of this I mean that would be
crazy Jared Kushner I could see that's
your son-in-law a Bloody Mary your
daughter but Don Jr I think if he
disavows Jared Kushner he would insist
that his daughter Ivanka unconverted
Judaism and go back to whatever reasons
as well whatever religion we believe is
is Donald Trump's religion yeah so I
follow a bunch of people on Twitter who
have made claims over the last 6 to 12
months about the Trump in Russia
investigation who have been vindicated
who have been right they are saying the
next three weeks are going to be
absolutely and utterly insane and we'll
see if that's the case send me your
thoughts about all of this I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show and I'm
looking forward to hearing from you
today's program sponsored in part by
Blink is comm slash Pakman I've talked
about blinkers before it's this awesome
app that I've been using for several
months now and what it does is take the
best and most critically acclaimed
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks that you can
listen to in one sitting you could
listen to ten books in an afternoon I
know that many in our audience want to
expand their horizons and learn more
about all sorts of different topics but
we're mostly limited by time to some
degree i know i'm not able to read all
of the books that i want simply because
i've got other stuff going on and that's
why blink is - such a great tool you can
absorb the most important information
and insights from the book in one
sitting and our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube click the link in the video
description and after that free trial if
you like
blinka stand I think you are going to
like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about five bucks a month go to be li NK
is t.com slash PA k ma n